amazing oh so good fantastic hello
welcome to Lobby G starts weekly hang
out every Tuesday at 2 p.m. Pacific
right here on gamespot.com shout out to
Mr Vinnie carll there Giant Bomb guys
have a live stream on this afternoon as
well check that out once this is done
but right now Watchdogs is finally out
so it's no surprise to anyone that we're
going to play Watchdogs and give away
and we're going to give away a hell a
bunch of Watchdog stuff like these video
games oh yeah who's watching these video
games the
Watchdogs also humor Peter yeah know
who's watching my script nobody Peter
Brown's going to be on later with the
Retron 5 plus we've got super ballerina
up bounding but for now my name is
Daniel dwire join as ever my partner in
crime lover of Nazi weapons Mr Chris
Waters and Tomy CH is here to show us
off the video game Mario Kart a which
comes out Friday how is this game not
out yet we reviewed it like a month ago
I know because Nintendo had so much
confidence that people are going to love
it that they're like we're going to give
you two weeks to digest all the words
and the reviews yeah and you really like
it I loved it it's amazing Co let's let
I feel like we should just hop straight
into it we should just hop right in
we're going to play the type of game
that is best enjoyed by playing and and
by playing in general just versus race
is that just going to be you versus me
no we're going to have computers but
then we can jump around we don't have to
do a cup and we can we can do as much as
we want I'm going to do lacu cuz lacu is
what is lacu he's the dude from Super
Mario Brothers who throws the spinies
sure I'm going to be this Koopa Kid with
fabulous hair ludig von Koopa it's king
ludvig from slash nenin if you any
questions for Tom and Chris about uh
Mario Kart by all means put them in the
chat put them in the twitch chat
Gamespot comments if GameSpot is up
because I know we're down at the moment
and if you can't get through to that
feel free to send them to ashh Gamespot
on Twitter yes yes I have chosen we're
going to do 150c because you are super
good at being 150c oh yeah how many
races do you think we're going to get in
eight probably Sol probably too many
we're probably going to do five yeah
probably more like that uh all right Tom
man give me to give on Mario Kart 8 how
is it similar and how is it different
than new uh what the heck kind of
question is this you want me to talk
about the game I want to talk about
video games so I really the thing that I
love about this game is that like so
recent Mario Kart games have been kind
of a mess where you'd be hit by blue
shells and like if you were in first it
was a punishment you talking about like
Mario Kart 7 on 3DS Mario Kart 7 was
much better than that but like the Wii
version and Double Dash and 64 like it's
just kind of been a theme especially
with the Mario Karts mhm DS was also
like that this game is totally like if
you get into first and you're good you
can stay in first which is crazy to
think about because it just hasn't been
in a Mario Kart game in in many many
many years it used to be that you'd
often try and get to this the front like
as late as possible yeah like that was
an actual tactic you would it would not
be who you to be in first which is which
is crazy that you would want to do that
um and of course I'm I'm showing how
good that is but I'm in seventh place
right now bad nailing it Tom I know I
know and I chose my favorite course in
the game too this is the one retro
course that is from Super Mario Kart
which is still my favorite in the series
how many Throwbacks are in this then
Rainbow Road counter four what do you
what did you ask how many throwback
levels are oh there's 16 throwback
levels so there's no there's no battle
arenas or battle specific Arenas there's
none of those cool old battle stuff but
yeah there's 16 16 new tracks 16 retro
like but they made edits to them right
yeah like this this thing where I just
jumped in the water there that's not in
the original
you can't JP in the water on the Super
Nintendo jeez features even with mode s
you couldn't do that you've got the
boomerang there as well right I got it's
a new thing uh I don't know what else
there's to say about it other than it's
a boomerang I got a piranha that's also
a new thing I'm going to try to Chomp
somebody you can successfully CH people
with the piranha that gives you like a
speed boost as well oh yep and it makes
me un be around turns yeah because it
it's like grabbing the ground and
boosting you H I'm going to ask a bunch
of questions cuz y'all on Twitch be
throwing them real quick uh Danny hiiki
asks is dry bones an unlockable
character
no no that is a cry of dismay from Tom I
like dry bones dryon he he and Diddy are
the two characters who were in previous
games that I most lamented were not in
this is W Bones on unlockable character
yes okay he Isen non-conical glistening
bones H yeah moist bones here we go wait
that sounds bad yellow Sanchez asks will
Mario Kart 8 be coming to the 3DS no but
it's better that I can't believe I got
four that's terrible I know you're ninth
but you didn't play the game as much as
me I didn't play the game for 30 hours
and three three Gold Cup every Cup on
the cup circuit I don't want to brag but
you can brag for me can I talk to you
about the Battle level stuff because
this was quite a and I was quite
irritated when I saw this so the battle
mode in this game generally the battle
levels are kind of like
self-enclosed Arenas so what what's
happened this time cuz they're not
Arenas they're just like kind like
circuits they're just circuits so it's
just race angry it's a loop of a one of
these tracks has been converted into a
battle arena they just Loop it and
everyone starts at different places on
the course and like some facing
different directions there's no like hey
you're going the wrong way lud that's
lit that's going to come down uh they've
made some changes to it but it's like
very spread out yeah yeah there's Bots
there's Bots there's B in the we'll
check it out at some point after we play
these five races so you guys can see
what they are but it's not like battle
mode hasn't been great for like a decade
but I don't think that's the way to fix
it I thought that they could go on a
different way em em any ideas what Tom
said Tom was is pining for a different
battle mode I'm just wondering if he has
any ideas I don't know I mean I would I
I still like battle mode in all the
games but I guess it hasn't like the the
first two Mario Karts I love battle mode
M I guess it hasn't had the same
excitement since it's kind of the same
old thing every time but I guess just
making the courses worse doesn't make it
better for me
weirdly H Eminem stranger asks do I need
to have played all seven of the previous
games to understand this one yes okay
definitely uh Bob Jones 1980 is is
online play any
good it's fine whatever I mean it's what
you'd expect you play online against
people how many people uh 12 oh really
which is a lot of people be playing
Mario Kart with yeah do you tend to get
12 people when you were doing it I guess
it's not a yet so just no one did not
get 12 people but yeah Mario Mario
Kart's always good online like it's the
chat's kind of garbage and you can't
chant during races but like whatever
yeah is there split screen online yes
but only two player you can't play four
player shame uh technology dude
technology Crimson Jester asks Pro
Controller or Gamepad uh I only use the
game pad but it's not super great but
whatever it's got there's a big button
on it for horn there's a big button on
it for can I touch it you can you can
touch it all you want D you're going to
touch your where is it it's the giant
Cloud where is it it's right there where
you yep is it coming out of the actual
TV or is it only coming out of the gam
pad I think it's coming out of the TV I
can't hear
it how often does the super horn show
off ask stion at 102 uh well as you as
you've noticed we we played almost six
track or six whatevers laps laps laps
and uh neither both have got Tom don't
be in first right so that's that's the
one for getting rid of the blue shell
right yes or any item really it just
neutralizes any incoming item situation
it's it's pretty rare uh there's also
blue shells aren't that prevalent I mean
we've actually gotten one in each race
which is a lot usually it's not even one
per race the lightning is a lot of
lightning in this game come on you small
child David Fox 1983 asked I heard the
frame rate goes down from 60 after you
introduce a certain amount of players I
noticed this when we did four players oh
yeah so it goes down to about 30 so the
way it actually works with four players
is the game this is really technical do
you want me to talk techn so digital
found broke this stuff down the game
always runs at 60 frames a second when
it's four player the top screen and
bottom screen alternate they refresh
rate okay so it's like top refreshes and
bottom and like that so they both run at
30 frames a second but the HUD moves at
60 frames a second okay uh and there's
actually another weird thing so every 60
this is really technical okay you guys
ready for this every 64th frame is
duplicated right which some people swear
they see a hitch but I I didn't hear
anyone say that before digital Foundry
talked about it I'm just going to throw
I'm just going to go out of a limb and
say I didn't hear anyone mention you can
see you can pick out one of every 64
frames with your eyes and see a hitch
like it's I I don't I don't see it even
like when I'm told like right the 138
Mark I don't I don't see that but if you
have really sensitive eyes you want to I
don't know I I feel bad if you can
notice that but so what's your overall
visual impression of the this game is
ridiculously goodl looking ridic like
you are so fusive about it what do you
love so much about it I mean it's
colorful it's got some nice
environmental detail it's going I don't
know it just doesn't it does look pretty
it it look so good and it's just like a
game I want to exist in cuz it look it
just looks you want to live in this are
you having like Avatar God yes yes yeah
this is his new life now this is my new
life I've played so many hours of this
game Koopa kids are his friends at dude
in B dude I'm baked on Twitch asks can I
play with my friends online without
having them next to me presumably this
person is usually pretty smoked up in
his room when he wants to play some
Mario Kart I get paranoid when people
are next to me is it random uh uh
matches or play with people but it's
like you can't it's not like an invite
system Nintendo is you can't like find
someone on your Wii U friend zone list
I'm pretty sure you can't do that it's
just like Nintendo's so backwards Wii U
friend zone the you friend yeah I just
do not Bob Jones so so if you had a
friend have a friend like in a
hypothetical situation like how would
you actually connect with them just like
I think you both go to the room I don't
know it's kind of creepy there's a lot
of by the room are you referring to
their living room yeah that's so much
better like Mario Kart's not supposed to
be online all right spoking speaking of
uh fun I actually used to go into the
lobby of my uh apartment for DS and I
would just play it all alone in a chair
I'm in first yay Blue Shield uh I call
this the sunny Bono bomo Memorial Run
and car doesn't like when I do that
because that's dark humor cuz that's
really dark humor H Tom does the frame
rate drop with three players to chatar
rasi I think it's more than two uh let's
test it out next race quit edit this
when you're done let's I'm not super
sensitive with that kind of stuff no
worries it always ran smooth than me
whatever Bob Jones 980 asks what's the
local um um sorry what's the maximum am
of local players you can have what war
it should be five why cuz you could put
it on the tablet you could put one of
the players on the tablet
let find find nintend but whatever I
know some games have had five right
Rayman rayman's had five yeah but wasn't
one of those five Murphy Oh Murphy's
such an idiot arabas ask is Shy Guy the
best character in the game uh no Cooper
CH is good question Good
Question come on get
some it's cage out on the slopes uh I
like this track because it doesn't loop
at all I know there's two tracks like
that I think there's two tracks that
don't Loop that's one of the reasons I
chose it I actually called out this in
my uh review I like the Wario Wario
track tell I'm going to get you with a
boomerang in the face oh it didn't come
back oh what to had you I all right
let's get me in on this is there another
controller there's another controller
under here what else can you use do you
want the nunchuck or do you want the Pro
Controller oh give me the pro is that
wireless sure sure it is I mean not
technically W Wireless there's a there's
a wire between the things all right so I
can change this the gam pad to a map to
map okay which you never look down at I
get it yeah but I don't know why I would
ever do that well then if you play split
screen it shows the split screen I know
grid on the tablet it shows the the four
player split it's like what this is your
Tech Nintendo this is your thing put use
the tablet in a cool way that's not just
honking I'm hitting it's not oh griping
number two wishful thinking am I number
two I'm number one I don't know all
right I'm in does did the light who's
not in what I'm in what you're not in
how did you oh you were cuz you were
lwig that was confusing me are you with
someone yeah no I'm going to goone oh
yeah okay I'm going to be shy guy cuz
that person in the chat I'm going to be
Wario you can pick your your your setup
as well your your frame and your wheels
and stuff how you not into that I I just
think it just detracts from the game I
think it's just nonsense this isn't yeah
that's nonsense I it's like I don't need
to Tinker I just want to play a game
that's fun I don't so it's not are you
comparing my card to Forza because I'm
could put a daffodil on my freaking yeah
okay I mean I don't know and like Danny
it's called The Livery not to name names
but Ma Max McGee used to spend forever
like trying to figure out I don't I
don't you know I don't want to wait for
that set I am impatient so we are now
doing I guess I'll make them can I make
them hard we do battle oh no we're doing
battle we're doing battle battle can you
do it without computer people just three
people it's super boring you want to do
can you though no no just you can okay
it is it's you you need it so we can do
any track want we'll do this one that is
a Yoshi Island track Yoshi Valley oh
this is the one where you drive off the
edge all the time if you're some if if
you're not good so Rainbow Road isn't
there future Rainbow Road in this yeah
AR all rainbow roads Future No some are
magical some are some are from the
distant past in a galaxy far far away
which which ones go I don't know I've
somehow managed to choose a motorcycle
it's good thing we're on battle mode cuz
I just started in Reverse wait so who's
down in the bottom right just the
computer yeah and on Races it shows
who's in first but it no it's not the
computer it shows who's in first in RAC
but I don't know who it's it showing me
because I'm good stff it's just a
glamour shot of Tom do we have the
computers playing so this is an example
of the frame
rate sure bam that's a thing eat it
whatever you just were that was near
me like I I'm not sure on Twitch if you
can really if you could have told you
know could tell other like earlier that
it was better but but it's definitely
you can tell yeah I can tell I can yeah
like it's you know it's not really
hindering my experience of playing Mario
Kart but still it's like you say that
like it's like Mario you say with this
like you spit it out no it's like Mario
Mario Kart it's I don't
know nice try Sucker from
downtown n I'm using the tactic of just
staying the godamn hell away from all
you Jokers how how are you knowing where
we Jokers is I'm going around in circle
basically oh here we go get away from
me oh no I ran into a thing a banana P
oh in your face who face
calm I mean if it wasn't one of you it
was calm so I probably stuck it to the
calm winning again oh dang it Tom Wario
what I do what do you mean what you you
know what you did okay I can't really
see anything specific keep getting one
green shell every time lucky
don't brag about it I'm going to go sit
on that bridge like a big fat troll I'm
going to shoot you off this bridge I
guess technically I would be under the
bridge if I was a real troll so it's
like Anthony Kus he's a troll I thought
that movie was that song was about drugs
was it was he a troll the whole time
every one of his songs is about heroin
Andor hell Slavic every one of their
songs it's crazy it is true you say
Halal Slavic he's the guy he's their
first guitarist who died from heroin in
like 85 hey Tom guess what just happened
I know you got
rock when I get to drive what were you
guys saying when you said Halal Slavic I
thought you meant like you know meat
that you can eat as a Muslim that's from
Poland that's not what he meant no what
was it was R's first guitarist okay you
died of a heroin overdose person's name
yeah oh I see you know who didn't die of
a heroin overdose go us shy guy who's
I'm in
second segue and how do you know you're
in second sorry I've got two balloons
that's not what that means I have five
my number says five what does that even
mean Tom what does the number mean am I
just player five how many people are
left I can I just say I I'm I'm nothing
against Mario I'm going to reverse right
into Mario oh dang it what were you
saying Danny can I just say yeah I the
the battle modes thing I really wish
this was an arena how do you feel about
it chuz it just makes everyone feel very
spread out you can't like it feels like
it's harder to line up vectors yeah
how do we what what what yeah so is it
because I had that many hits Tom we back
to her I'm not answering I don't want to
play anymore what battle mode sucks
Racing's better well no we're back to
racing you're supposed to answer
questions that are asked of you that's
your job on this show I'm going to see
if there's any more questions you guys
play I'm going to see if there's any
more questions you jump back in Chris
yes okay okay I'm going to be
1 you can tell that she's a girl she has
a bow Danny is there a single s Le
character name in the twitch chat has
anyone made mention of any character at
all pink gold Peach it is Shy Guy you
are such a TR late it's pink gold Peach
you are such a trouble um can you use
that as a steering wheel as a question
yes you can if you're weird would you
want to use that as whe it yeah I'll do
it yeah I'll do it okay I need something
putation what does that mean if you
can't if you can't succeed with the
steering wheel I probably won't be able
to succeed it's a steering wheel for
s you should see me drive in real life
it's uh it's not good for pedestrians or
other not succeed with a steering wheel
in real life Su Sun F asks what the
upgrade system for the car parts are
like do you unlock those bits or are
they all just there automatically yeah
you upgrade them by uh getting coins
okay so coins not only give you speed
but they also they go towards getting a
daffodil or whatever so when you they
don't upgrade it just alternate opens
new ones yeah every 500 or something you
collect is 500 or 50 it's a big
difference but every X number just
automatically gives you I'm going to say
50 I'm going to say 500 uh can we play a
new
track I put random actually oh okay H
you collected every single star in this
game and it didn't give you anything
well you don't collect Stars it's it's
that's that's like a rating to like if
you get all first in every cup you get
three star rating and it uh you get you
get something for getting
oh jeez he's doing it he's doing the
steering look at him look at him do it
worst look he's shaking it you know he's
getting desperate it must be trying to
aim that thing with the I will I'm going
to do it successfully I don't try oh
damn it I did try and I
failed uh come on Tom believe in
yourself do it yes in your heart I
totally just hit someone with the
boomerang Waluigi and he's not the
winner this is how you have to hold it
like above your head like a real driving
car right this how I really if you're
like a 5-year-old driving a real car oh
oh no right in the
drink not that is a nasty drink that's
like a brown goopy drink Hass on Twitch
ask milshake hasson on Twitch asks why
are there so many baby characters why
are there so many baby characters listen
babies there are five baby characters
babies are one of the top five types of
humans there are so it really makes
sense for them to be statistically
represented what's the worst baby
character they put in this game Baby
Daisy okay cuz Daisy is already like an
artificial character and that she does
do even exist outside the they're all
artificial characters she doesn't exist
outside the sports universe so like
she's not even she I don't think she
does does she I don't know what game is
she in I don't know she have her own
spin-off and then DA's rocking ride she
have an arcade game in Japan I don't I
don't think so it's like then having
like a and then there's like the pallet
swap there's Metal Mario and there's
pink gold Peach which are
nonsense Gold Peach don't you say that
about pink gold Peach what is for the
longest time though I actually thought
it was two colors like pink gold and
no Pink gold is a type of metal it's a
metal Pink Gold just like just like
metal is a type of metal in Metal Mario
yeah I didn't whatever I thought it was
like whatever they couldn't even make
him titanium Mario I know and my review
for seven when when Metal Mario was
first in Mario Kart I said like that's
not even a real character and apparently
I still stand by this cuz I write fat
and fiction and he's not a real
character apparently Daisy was in Mario
Land the movie Daisy there's a movie
Daisy called Mario Land Maryland and the
movie oh and the she was in the Bob
Hoskins get up canonical that's if
that's not canon I don't know what it is
I didn't okay well she was in Mario Land
that's something something I guess more
than you are in yeah it's one more than
I was DA's IMDb is way uh so she's like
the portable princess whoa is that her
thing whoa I don't know the portable
princess come on that's got that's a
NCH and then the other one is Beach are
they both princesses I want some Daisy
fan
pick be careful what you wish for Tom
turning is so hard when it's turning
like I'm going to do the whole I'm doing
the whole race and I'm switching back
pink gold Peach is number one a normal
mode nice work thanks Danny congratul I
appreciate your support always meant a
lot to me have you in my corner this oh
God this is you're not honking the horn
enough he's doing it you do it no more
look at the screen that's the whole
screen more faster that's a weird
horn
slower Mario Kart Ace what did it guess
what score it get an ace right there
Mario Kart Ace they got two more games
until they get a perfect score good job
Nintendo how you do it h yeah we got a
bunch of stuff to give away on today's
show uh I know we're giving away away
some Watchdog stuff later on but I
believe we're also giving away a bunch
of keys for monochroma which is out
today as
well it's Rober H hey what's up what's
up Robert you're GNA drop the special
edition what is what is the meaning of
this so now here we have Rob uh modeling
the contents of the
monochroma uh collector's edition you
get that shirt no come out here come out
here you get that uh scarf you do not
you do not get the cigarette all no for
me okay okay hey he's coming in and is
the video game it's the video game gam
spots Rob Handlery thank you very much
for you do not get the Beret being Sly
racist today um what's in the box what's
in the box uh bunch of art uh there's a
bunch of art can we hear him that's
that's about it bunch of art I think the
game's in here as well yeah where'd you
get that scarf is this your French
accent yeah
pointure
you have a light by the way oh it's a
menthol France I get it yeah yeah okay
got it that's the whole joke yeah and
you can win H you can win this or if you
don't win this you win one of uh five
other Keys we have for the regular ass
version of monochroma H to win that all
you have to do is follow game looking
good buddy it helps if you're from
France thank you rob H use the hash GS
Lobby and make sure you're following us
and uh then the screen will flash green
and you might win uh yeah so get those
in make sure following us so we can uh
we can shoot you those codes NOP nope
that's not happening I quit this year
man give me back in the wagon uh yeah so
that's that's that Rob do you have any
um you didn't review the game I'm just
supposed to come out here I'm not sure
if you've actually ever played it before
I have not played it I I edited the
review Tom played it oh yeah Tom loved
it yeah all right well if you want to
read that review or watch it go to
gamespot.com we'll be back in a second
once I get this dirty Frenchman off our
set
so
h
oh
no chroma kind of looks like Shindler
list the video game check out the review
for that on gamespot.com asgs the lobby
make sure you're following us on Twitter
if you want to win one of those codes or
the special edition Chris Waters hey
Daniel D my friend a great I had a great
long weekend oh yeah what you really fun
I went to ride roller coasters ride
roller coasters no to ride roller went
to an amusement park I didn't play any
video games what mum Park was it Great
America sounds down San Jose an American
I rode the ride formerly known as Top
Gun they built a new wooden roller
coaster I didn't think they were doing
that anymore but yeah that little nice
little rickety action there's a I went
nearly went on one but I jibbed out it
was uh in San Jose it's like the oldest
wooden roller coaster the grizzly is
that what it is yeah yeah is that San
Jose or Sant Cruz San Jose maybe you're
thinking of Santa Cruz boardwalk though
cuz there's some old roller coasters
there as well it's really terrifying
it's way more scary when the thing is
like vibrating and being rickety and
stuff that's like is this an intended
consequence that of the adrenaline this
ride is making me try to feel or is that
just because it's a little bit old I
grew up beside a town that had like a
fun fair and there were like a
terrifying number of incident incidents
may or may not have involved hear I only
got trapped on ride once okay yeah and I
wasn't upside down or anything so it was
only modly unpleasant that's still in
the back of my head every single time
don't like it Anyway video games yeah
one of the video games that I played at
Pax is a game called bounden is this the
game you described earlier as a ballet a
up yeah ballerina up ballerina up it's
this crazy game where uh the dude who
made it was there myself and Drew
Scallan from uh Giant Bomb played it
where you basically each of you hold on
to the iPad on one side of it and the
game this a dramatic reenactment of you
and Drew scanland I'm not sure the
actors they got to play you are quite
represented no these people are way more
beautiful and European more Dutch way
more Dutch uh yeah so you kind of the
game asks you know it's got a 3D ball
and you're basically like arcing the
phone between each other to make sure
that it lines up with the the dots he
actually like did this crazy amount of
he he did the choreography with like
this Russian ballet troop really but it
works really good like it works
immediately which you wouldn't think cuz
it kind of looks like you know if you
have bad spatial awareness you might not
be very good at it it looks like you
might end up uh sharing a tender moment
with someone who you'd play that game
with I wonder well it's a good thing
that we have uh gamespot's you know
resident French dude Rob Handler and uh
uh Max here to show off H Jesus Christ
Max hbert who appears to be dressed as a
pimp you got to set the scene as Santa
pimp and Robbie the French guy okay boys
could you uh could you get
in it would be an honor
Danny uh yeah so you're going to hold uh
one side of the uh the phone each once
they get into your messages because I
believe this is your phone yeah I nobody
text me right now please in my
contacts yeah this is a proper greeting
oh what in lie of actually having the
ballerina background you just put Beauty
in the beast on they're just Disney
dancing scenes they're some of the most
iconic uh encounters between men and
beasts ever to be filmed have you guys
played this before we practice all night
they practice all night that it those
cherubs are really into it oh uh-oh
uh-oh okay uhoh one hand you only only
one of you can lead is this
Titanic no this is definitely not
Titanic wait where's Billy Zayn no it's
like four weddings in a funeral or
something or it's babe cuz there's James
Cromwell there's going to be
there's going to be a really good um
over overhead one pretty soon I think
wait in Mansfield park there you go may
your you guys are getting off frame rob
you got to back up buddy sh get back we
were too slow oh you suck you lost wait
this makes no sense why are the hippos
those hippos are more graceful than you
all right you got one more go with this
you're literally the worst people we
could have gotten to do this Danny I
like how this is a game like the trailer
is just like people like having a lot of
fun together like and discovering it and
like moving in syn and we're turning
this into some Grim competition in which
we Heckle the hell out of these guys
while they do it and they're dressed up
as a pimp stop the pendulum move you
guys got to get a move it's giv us use
your there we go come on Christ you're
as graceful as a dead hip your hips are
locked up we did it we passed did you
passed congratulations hooray hooray
they did it oh my
God nobody puts Santa pimp in a corner
well well done well done a it's Bandon
it's out currently on iOS yeah it is
it's actually really good fun uh and you
will look more graceful than those two
jokers pretty impossible not to Jesus uh
we got a it didn't fall down no that's
true they did not fall down but uh later
on we'll do it with some drinks in them
and they probably will uh we got a bunch
more stuff coming up in the show
including Watch Dogs including your
chance to win one of these bad boys Tech
Time with Peter br's going to be on in
just a few minutes but first a word from
our sponsors see you in a minute stick
around hey what's up welcome back to the
lobby all right you guys have boys and
girls have been good let's give away
some stuff watch dogs now Xbox One PS4
we also have watch doog
t-shirts there's a spoiler on the home
screen of the menu of this video game
which irritated me don't look at the
menu of the video I'm not going to talk
about it now I'll talk about it later
there a spoiler on the menu menu I bet
with that face uh what on a t-shirt
right right is it only a spoiler because
you just said it was a spoiler maybe I
don't know if it is a spoiler I'm
guessing it oh you don't know I'm
inferring it's a spoiler uh then you
can't come on man right I've just spoil
everyone El now I'm sorry if you want to
win one of these bad boys uh follow
Gamespot on Twitter use #j lobby as ever
H just make sure you let us know what
version you want PS4 or Xbox One H we're
going to give those out over the course
of the show but first of all Peter Brown
hello thank you for waiting patiently
while I got all the housekeeping and and
spoiling the new video game Ed away it's
wonderful great to have you here this is
uh it's Tech time as ever I saw over the
weekend we put on a sorry that wasn't
dismissive as ever Tech as ever guess
it's time to look at some [__]
technology uh you've been playing the
Retron 5 for the past couple of weeks I
know you've been working with those guys
because it's the hardware isn't out
there yet um your review went up over
the weekend sort of breaking down the
pros and cons but at the moment uh and
you're going to show us it now can you
just give us a ski on what exact how
what is this machine first of all and is
it f for the purpose intended right now
yes yeah okay so basically what this is
is a a new system that plays a lot of
old games you have Nintendo Super
Nintendo Genesis but also the Japanese
variants you got famicom super famicom
and then Game Boy Game Boy Color and
Game Boy advaned games as well uh now
you need to have the original cartridges
for this and hyperkin released a few
products like like this in the past this
is their latest one it uses an embedded
Android operating system okay which
means that it's basically it's using
emulation right it's not a uh a onetoone
system but the cool thing about that is
you have HDMI out you can do things like
put graphical filters on you can use
safe States uh if you're really bad at
old games like me even though games are
hard yeah and I'm really bad at that so
so safe States kind of give me an upper
hand uh but yeah I mean this thing is
it's not quite perfect it's not quite
there yet it's coming out June 6th after
like 10 months of being delayed yeah um
but for the most part it's pretty great
um in terms of the imperfections are we
talking software stuff that they can
like push new firmware to it or yeah so
that's another great thing it's Android
so they can update it uh right now
there's some incompatibility with a few
games they use special chips um but it's
it's not that that many games that don't
really work um oddly you can't have more
than one cartridge in the system at a
time but there's four slots for
cartridges I know you can't just stack
them up no you can't but that that
should that should change hopefully um
can we have look at the controller as
well CU obviously this is this is this
the only one you can use no you can use
original controllers Super Nintendo
Genesis or Nintendo okay and those can
all be reprogrammed for any of this
systems you want and if you have four
controllers for any system you can plug
those in and pretend like you have a
multi-tap and play four player games wow
uh the one thing you can wait you say
you can you can play like Genesis games
with a Super NES controller you got it
wow that's weird or with a Nintendo
controller if you're weird um like at NS
one but uh what you cannot do is
multiplayer Game Boy games because that
requires a Link cable and that's not
really a thing with this okay MH but it
seems to take a lot of boxes takes a lot
of boxes how is this guy cuz it's got an
analog stick on it not d-pad right well
so what it has is a it's a pad with
micro switches underneath okay um which
is good for things like fighting games
show it again hold it up to your mic and
move it around a little bit yeah it's
right here no no no like actually the
thumb stick cuz it makes makes clicky
noises is it like an eight-way kind of
feel it like clicks at the stations
right up down left right diagonals it's
kind of obnoxious and cheap feeling to
be honest with you but it works and uh
yeah well here we're going to play some
Sonic 3 why don't we do that yeah yeah
let's hop straight in so this is a game
that an old cartridge that you had um I
know people are going to ask so I'll
just ask get it away this thing does not
take ROMs or anything of that nature
right no um but you know it's running
Android and if the uh you know nerd
Community has taught me anything it's
that they will hack anything that they
can right and uh that will probably
include this over time but for the
moment yeah it's totally locked down to
legit cartridges and you know I collect
games anyway like I I use emulation when
I have to but for the most part I really
appreciate having the real thing so for
me this is wonderful because I actually
get to play the games on Modern TVs
without the like delay present with
upscaling from old systems uh nothing a
problem in terms of like uh HDMI with
htcp or with with anything of that
nature no totally no awesome if you have
any questions for Peter uh same as ever
put them in the chat put them in the
comments uh I'll send them I have a
question let's do it what you got so
this is the Retron five yep you're
probably wondering what happened to the
Retron 4 so there have been retrons
before this and we've you know we've had
them in the office and we played around
with them uh is there a story about the
Ron 4 you want to tell or can we or do
you just want I I was curious about like
the iteration like where what what has
been added in here what what makes this
like the the I mean has been vastly
improved over what you can get maybe an
older system I mean yeah basically so
the Retron 4 was announced um about a
year and a half ago and that was what
the Retron 5 is now but then they added
support for Game Boy games um so that
kind of changed up the whole number
scheme and well hell just they're not
going to come out with a Retron 4 I
don't think was there a three once you
get that high in the numbers you're feel
feel free to skip any number you want
that's the that entertainment has set
that precedent for so is there a
situation in which like you should wait
until the Retron 6 comes out like so
Nintendo 64 is the one cartridge system
that a lot of people are asking for um
the only reason that's not in here is
because the patent on the hardware is
still valid okay uh so once that runs
out I believe in 2016 wow don't quote me
on that um they should have something in
you know that will play Nintendo 64
games the guys have already said at
hyperen the company that makes this that
they they have that working in house
it's just not a product that they can
put on the market so how far away from
me from ouch yeah nice work how faros
Emerald for you
Sonic how far away from having like
Playstation One versions of this are we
well I mean I think that's going to come
down to what they want to do as a
company right because you know these you
don't have moving Parts in these right
it's just a cartridge slot and like an
embedded Android computer PlayStation
stuff you're going to have you know
discs to contend with and moving parts
and lenses and it's a lot more you know
places for things to go wrong and
hyperin is is facing a bout of consumer
lashback because this been delayed so
long and the price was raised even 40%
as well how much is it $140 okay so it
was 100 bucks before it was $100 um they
their initial manufacturing uh process
led to some errors and they actually
redesigned the chassis to support Sega
Master System games and to fix the
errors that uh they were experiencing I
don't really know what those were um but
you know uh overall I like this thing I
uh this is one that they sent us for a
review I'm probably going to buy one of
my own for home um because like I said
playing games damn it talking yeah you
do it uh I'm not doing crap over there I
can't talk and play at the same time uh
if you see meab bit you know it uh
basically you know when you try to use
old systems which I actually prefer to
do it it's better on a CRT TV because
the timing is right the games look the
way they should on an LCD they're
they're totally stretched you press a a
few milliseconds or frames later that's
when it actually takes and that's not
really good for when games are so
difficult um I've got a couple of
questions here going to get you quick
anti anti has asked does it have any CRT
emulation filters yes it does have a
scan Line Filter you can throw on top
and it has the similar filters you would
find in emulators such as like super
eagle and all those great naming things
that smooth out the pixels uh yeah do
you actually want to poke around in the
menu of this at all oh yeah yeah what
don't we do uh I'll show you guys what
we got uh turn on so there's that Save
State stuff you got you can pop these
filters on just right from the in-game
menu
yeah there are the scan lines which take
away some of the smoothing but you can
you can tell even without even with the
scan Line's present that it's a little
bit nicer at nle leg ask have you ever
noticed any lag when any of the
emulations while running on HD no
because this uh outputs native
resolution to your TV so there is no
processing of the video uh at least in
terms of the TV which before was the the
ulation happens or where lag happens all
right cool um so yeah it's pretty great
sweet uh thanks very much Peter coming
on and showing off the Retron 5 U I'm
not going anywhere I'm going to keep
playing you keep playing son 3 all day
you can sit there if you want oh I want
cuz as much as many old games as there
are to play there are also new games
what there are every single week there
is a new game to play and I think Mary
Kish is here to tell us all about them
maybe even more than one new game hey up
Mary Mary I am here to tell you and
unlike other weeks this week I really do
have some really good new games to talk
to you guys about
yeah Watch Dogs came out and we have
Mario Kart 8 coming out on Friday so
that's going to be pretty big week and
then there's actually some other stuff
uh worms what finally worms is out
finally thanks Team 17 they added some
new stuff it's worth talking about still
they did they added like some new ways
to kill each other cuz when you're at
War for so long yes they did ask me
again did they yes all right let's go
let's show some Watch Dog footage right
playing this in a little bit but we do
have Oo we have uh Watch Dogs coming out
today yeah popping off baby Aiden and uh
it's coming out on all sorts of stuff uh
Xbox One 360 PS4 PS3 and PC um it looks
the best on PC is that a dog watching
Watch Dogs it is nice who is watching
The Watch Dogs then we have worms uh
this is Worms Battlegrounds for Xbox one
now it's being ported Xbox one uh and
that comes out on Friday they have some
new stuff that you haven't seen before
uh like different different kind of like
ways to kill each other they came out
with like a whoopy cushion um but then
they still have the old ones if you like
those of course they do that's all they
do monochroma Dan you like worms was so
delightfully shown earlier with the
scarf and hat which finally we get to
some context for the actual shirt and
scarf that you get in that
Prize did you yeah yes did you I mean
yes that comes out May 28th um and then
this one's pretty interesting I thought
this was something like Danny you might
end up finding like Danny play at some
point it's called kill the bad guy it's
on PC and you basically just find really
elaborate ways to kill that bad guy by
like running him over and slicing off
his head and then burning the remains oh
my God it's good for you know every
light-hearted individual who kind of
just like wants to vent out their
frustrations and then finally of course
you have Mario Kart so oh my God that
plane's going to land on Mario's head
Run Mario Jesus actually it's running
out of running out of Fairway
there anyway so this is coming out on
Friday Friday what is with Nintendo in
their crazy release date to come out
Tuesdays are the the day but it's weird
and Watch Dogs was a was an
international release this uh this week
as well so that's right Europe managed
to we were still under embargo and they
were playing it in Europe everyone all
over the globe gets to enjoy the great
City of Chicago CH the windy apple chai
Town yeah all right well that's it so
get out there and go enjoy some games
thanks Mar thank you Mary chitan Kanye
West is currently in Ireland on his
honeymoon at the moment did you know
that Kevin vanard I did know that as a
matter of fact did you really yeah I did
know that why because he's Irish and it
only makes sense is it because you have
a Yahoo alert for
Kim no no are there does Yahoo actually
have alerts I know this is the is Yahoo
still around Yahoo is gamot gamespot.com
still down gamespot.com was still down
last I knew well you're here to play
Watch Dogs before you do that um before
we actually go to that I want to remind
people # GS the lobby on if I hit the L
hit the L's real good
there if you want to win us on
PlayStation 4 Xbox one hash GS the lobby
at Gamespot make sure you put down your
platform of choice Kevin we'll be back
in a second but first of all I do
believe we've got a little little
snippet of all the stuff that's coming
up on original programming on Gamespot
this
week
hey remember that gun that shoots
[__] razor blades the tournament is
one of the greatest games ever made
you're a guy with a gun the game puts
Nazis on the other end of it and you
click until they get dead and move on to
the next batch today it's all about
Cartman Butters Kyle Stan and the
Beautiful Princess Kenny the biggest
game in the world is Mario Golf World
Tour did you uh get it right welcome
back to another week of top five scy
mods wow this one is is actually an hour
so this one was recommended To Us by the
way by corn spawn yeah thanks you
weirdo we'll just leave that we'll just
leave that here pet him pet him SE then
he won't kill
us you want to find all those videos
just go to the uh videos tab it drops
down from the top of gamespot.com when
gamespot.com works exactly but don't do
that now because the site's down oh my
God we've been hacked this whole website
Kev we did we got we got done a hack at
us with Julian ass has been sleeping in
the in the bathroom and somebody found
out now I'm pretty sure I saw a guy in a
weird scarf and a trench coat earlier
and a did is he wearing a scarf oh he is
he has like a little scarf under his
sweater some of his costumes have like
the whole like hey hey I'm a robber
thing yeah Kevin vanord Kevin vanord you
are here to show us watch dogs why are
we playing this on at the moment I am
this is an Xbox One okay um because this
is the version we had in the office I
was going to show off the PC version but
I would not necessarily recommend uh
grabbing that until um the issues are
fixed I've heard there are some problems
there are some problems with you play
okay so uh yeah I you do now uh so right
now we're playing on uh on Xbox One
playing on an Xbox one you've reviewed
this and you enjoyed this game I I like
this game a lot absolutely yes um it's
it's a good it's a really great sandbox
to just tool around in and and make fun
and I think I think that um it's one of
those games that actually was hurt by
its marketing because it was marketed so
heavily as as being like this super
serious kind of spy game dxy thing and
it has parts of that but really the
things this game does best is just being
a really being a really cool sandbox
letting you T-Bone soccer momone soccer
moms absolutely yeah I think that's a
really fair assessment I played the
first couple of hours and was kind of I
felt disappointed but then after a while
I'm kind of realizing I I was just
anticipating a different game the game
is different than the one I expected but
once you're able to let the expectation
go I'd say that this this game is right
up there with with the the big city
based open world heavyweights aw um I'd
say you know if you like Saints Row and
you like GTA it's almost a given that
you're probably going to have a lot of
fun with this game H if you have any
questions for Kevin about Watch Dogs by
all means stick them in the twitch chat
or on the Gamespot comments if the sit's
back up or on Twitter and uh we'll we'll
get them sent over how far are you
through watch dogs at the moment this is
the very towards the very beginning of
the game hey you see some people making
out and is not
appropriate brother runs grow up grow up
just cuz his brother her grows yeah she
recently went to Las Vegas and she's a
house sitter people do that for a living
like all the time so those are two
people that are not actively doing
horrendously crappy aoral things no
although I will say that if you are if
Watch Dogs is to be believed then the
people of Chicago are usually engaged in
terrible things when they think that
they're not being watched but they are
but they are being watched dogs what are
you doing what mission is this you going
so this is a CTO Tower so what this is
is you have to figure out how to get in
there um and so that you can hack into
it and un no that doesn't work and then
unlock um that different parts of the of
the of the city like you this is
basically like the Far Cry Assassin's
Creed Tower type thing so a lot of the
times you can get into like get into
cameras
um in this case you know there the fork
Clift might be in the way of the switch
that you need to get to this case it was
in the way of the camera that you need
to get to and there's the unlock did you
just driver San Francisco your way over
C basically that's that's kind of what I
call that riding the cameras it's like
my little like that's not an official
term that's just what I call it a good
term yeah so you just ride the cameras
around this case a pretty pretty easy um
route in there my favorite aspect of
that has been the COS like like
headquarter areas where you have to like
hack into them not the towers but like
the the the centers that they have no
totally um and like I remember turning
up outside one with all my guns and
thinking I'm going to have to shoot my
way through this and then never even
entering the area just using the cameras
and using almost like a puzzle game to
try and figure out the way of getting
over them yeah well even some of the you
can even approach some of the combat
encounters like that like you don't even
have to get sometimes you can solve
encounters without even getting into a
fight or having to do tradition sneaking
you can just finds to go through theer
and get to what you and just get the
hell out of there without even anybody
ever KN you were there you can't always
do that um or if you can I'm not clever
enough to have figured figured out
exactly how to do that all of the time
but H never know never know th over
great name is asking is there a
difference between the PS4 and Xbox One
versions I I believe that the PS4 runs
at a higher resolution you can sort of
tell the Xbox version the Xbox One
version seems to have a little bit more
uh you know you notice some of the
jaggies a little bit more and so on and
so forth and I think there's some
differences in the lighting model you
notice those if you go from one to the
other but for all intents and
purposes um the on the Xbox One it more
or less looks like the experience I had
on the PS4 yeah I played the Xbox One
version and it didn't look is that a
different couple making out no these are
the same people right has she recently
Tri oh wait wait wait no I think this
might be a different couple that guy
retired he's just now recovering from an
auto accident BR social ties with former
friends yeah that's the next to the Rock
by the sidewalk my favorite bug that I
came across was when uh this couple is
in in a bar and they look like they're
like very close to each other and
they're having a conversation I'm going
to do this uh fixer contract um they're
having a conversation but they're both
talking at the same time and both
talking about two different things okay
so it's it's one of those things where
where not only are they not having an
intimate conversation but they're
actually having two conversations at
once I had a situation where I Harmon is
the worst I had a situation where I
walked down the street and there were
three different people having the same
conversation yeah that that can
sometimes happen it's interesting those
things stick out all the more because
there's so much Variety in terms of when
you hack people so much Variety in terms
of the things they can actually um they
can actually be say and do some of and
people people of Chicago or have a lot
of sex do they they really do they they
also play with themselves lot as far as
I can tell uh girl Draco 7 asks does
watchog feel like a modern Assassin's
Creed how like Assassin's Creed does it
feel like not really I'd say I'd say Far
Cry 3 actually or yeah feels more like
Assassin's Creed than this does you can
you can leap over stuff but there's not
and there I guess you could call that
parkour but that doesn't have the same
real feel to it um I mean there are
elements the Ubisoft elements here in
terms of the way the systems interlock
you unlock systems so that you you can
get to other systems so that you can get
to other systems kind of thing um and
they jump into it pretty quickly yeah
they Assassin's Creed well Assassin's
Creed 3 took several hours to really
jump in Assassin's Creed 4 just moves
like the moment you get in so and this
one moves pretty much oh wait I thought
I was doing a different kind of contract
I thought I was doing a get into the car
and drive away contact I I didn't
contract I didn't realize that I was
doing the that's what your target is
doing getting into the car and driving
away this this is what happens when you
get me on on the on the uh the show and
uh I'm not paying any attention I'm
going to ask you a couple of questions
make sure you can't pay attention um is
it interesting to hack into the phones
and other stuff of random civilians in
the game uh or at one point do you just
meet the same people over and over again
it there is actually a lot of variety in
terms of the things that you see um and
and listen to there is there is some
repetition but I'd say in general like I
I probably hacked into hundreds of
people's phones and uh typically they've
been uh pretty pretty varied like I said
there there there so a lot of the same
themes come up like you come across a
lot of bros talking about their sexual
exploit sweet jump sweet jump swe jump
sweet jump sweet jump sweet
jump
yeah
nice that was uh undone by a humble
planter yeah but that tree is down yeah
I noticed that when I was playing is
these cars can just tear through
anything yeah these are and that's what
I mean about like the fun factor of this
game is a lot higher than I expected
it's not nearly as serious as I expect
it to be sometimes it tries but really
the the fun of Watch Dogs just comes
from you know the pure basic fun of a of
a really great sandbox so does that make
it feel like is it okay with you when it
tries to when you have the mission to
like take on the down the human
traffickers does it like feel like
that's in there just to give you some
evil people or does it like is it okay
like does it feel exploitative to you I
guess is my question every so often it
feels a little bit it has a little bit
of that where did he
go there's a little bit of that try to
hard kind of element going on some of
the time like it's like you know we let
you have your fun now we're going to get
serious here and we're going to we're
going to talk about human trafficking
and cannibalism and and we're going to
we're going to show we're going to show
a [__] in progress and that kind of
thing but can you do the mission where
you see a [__] in progress
Uh Kevin can you confirm or deny that
there's on coming by my place later
tonight or something or is that no no no
no that's uh no that was inappropriate
for for live internet television no I
love it look man this game is rated M
for mature and so is Kevin exact Kevin
rated M for Mature let's go to the story
Mission and see what's going on I don't
know how much more time I have but keep
going we got a bunch of questions here
as well go on the twitch CH is asking
what difficulty did you set it to what
did you feel most comfortable with this
is this is is on normal difficulty I
would actually say bump it up to hard um
maybe because uh the the the shooting is
a little bit on the easy side okay um
guy dudes are pretty quick to go down
when you shoot them even if you shoot
them in the non-head areas right um
which is to say when you don't shoot
them in the head leg yes you know
shooting them in the butt is a perfectly
fine tactic but that's like real life if
he shut someone in the butt they'd
probably go down yeah probably mhm mhm I
forgot
forgettable username asks does this dude
the main character have any personality
Aiden Pierce do we care about him he has
you know what I didn't really care the
whole thing with Aiden is he's kind of
defined by his relationship with his
sister yeah and the fact that he's
trying to get not that kind of
relationship he's trying to why is it
always got to be woe With You O dwire
that's his sister's house there right
there you're going to it right now got
start this Mission they call me W dwire
so so basically his thing is okay he's a
dude who's lost a female family member
and now he's out for Revenge it's
classic tale only in this case it's his
niece yeah so a lot of you know the good
first half of the story is really just a
bunch of stuff like that dealing with
that so you're about to go to his
sister's son his his nephew's um
birthday party and there's a little this
is and this is very early on get things
yeah this is very very early on um so
this this whole thing is is really
interesting because she's like Let It Go
stop it yeah and there's no real good
explanation for why he doesn't stop it
and it's one of my big irritations with
this character is she's like you're
putting us in danger why do you keep
doing that and he's and he promises like
he won't do it again and he'll stop and
and as we're about to see and he but he
lies
basically he just can't handle it he's
like he just lets himself be pulled in
it's like like he doesn't care in that
case he cares more about the Revenge
Quest than he does about the safety of
his family members the people that he's
originally trying to avenge it's really
strange and I think that part of like
what keeps him coming back isn't really
sufficiently explored in any meaningful
way but towards the end things start
getting really interesting like when it
gets all Tom clanes and they're all
talking about like like when he gets his
little Entourage together and they're
getting all hacky and you know when it
sounds like an episode of 24 or
something and then suddenly that gets
really interesting look at you and uh
you know there's some interesting stuff
about you look older the man who pulls
the trigger okay um that causes the car
accident that his knes dies in um they
deal with that in a some really
interesting ways and uh towards the end
he starts to finally get some
selfawareness
but for somebody who seems to be smart
enough to hack into almost anything he's
pretty hacked into himself has he no but
I should have said that in the review
there you go the hardest hack of all
let's let's skip this cuz it goes on for
a little while he can see your details
but he doesn't know his own own yeah
such a scathing commentary on the modern
condition no it's not Jackson and sweet
happy birthday I will say the lighting
on the console versions of this interior
can often be Happ fun the kids were
playing she in a deep Shadow right
beneath fun I very much like because it
goes upwards Chris can't you see that it
goes goes up and vanishes in the ceiling
why would you have the lights on during
the day because your house is a
Perpetual den of darkness and even the
lights and full sunlight can't keep the
darkness away so it does have some
visual tricks go into his bedroom
there's the the raving rabbits no no no
the other way the other way the other
way yeah there is a rabbit in there yeah
it's pretty
good that's the bathroom I know but I'm
picking stuff up pick meds pills here
you also pick up like different
compounds and combine them to make the
the various hacks that you can sort of
use in
combat or you can just check out our
emails you absolute bastards can you
hack your nephew's iPad you can hack his
rabid here's the
Rabbid there you can you can hack into
things like um baseball caps no does the
child have a Pac maker can you hack into
that who is this oh no vlogging ID will
hide you does your sister have a
vibrator phone she's getting called by a
well this is the whole thing this is the
whole story bit now is that now she's
being I know where you live can you
stand really close to her so that she
obviously knows that you're listening in
on the call and it breaks the you
feel why even act in you're just right
here you could probably hear his voice
coming out of Theo coming out of the
speaker at this stage that who is that
matter some yeah that's basically what
that is who was that what he
want so now this initiates basically the
whole return to the to the Revenge
return of the Revenge yeah just like
that Star Wars movie all right so he's
locating this is obviously just the game
playing out in its own way I feel like
this this is still part of the unlocking
the various mechanics thing yes yeah you
got to go murder that dude coming to get
you get I'm in Murder that's what I do
in driving unsafe in my nephew's
neighborhood I did find it a little bit
weird that like to catch people you like
started like auto accidents which are
didn't can be fatal there's like I felt
like I felt like when I killed people by
accident in this world I felt way worse
about
it like I know you lose reputation and
stuff but I also felt like like my my
niece died in a car crash and here I am
I'm going to go out somebody else's
niece's car crash no it's it really is
one of those things that doesn't always
make sense like the game like the story
sometimes tries to approach stuff like
that but not to any great degree like
like it's very very important oh oops
it's very very important that you um
just make me so cra sometimes that you
catch the dude yeah it you know Aiden's
you know Aiden's kind of oblivious to
everything that happens around him yeah
he seems like a sociopath just you're
doing it right now I can't he's just
having cars crash into you I know oh man
I wasn't able to do this uh the
bridge
oh there you go what did you
do took him
down I do love how he just completely
beats the absolute crap at him with whoa
he's got a
gun oh that's dark homicide committed
killed him in the leg it's the best kind
of kill get this
dude hack him hack him
just everything explodes in Chicago it
was worth this cuz I find a guy who was
prank calling my sister
Justice it really is don't you know how
tired that refrigerator joke is so
there's one place and I don't think this
is a spoiler there's one place where
he's basically like so so how's your
family yeah and I'm like Aiden dude this
is how you got into this mess because
somebody was like getting to your family
because of you now you're just doing the
same thing you're just as much of an
[__] as everybody else and they try
to make something of that in this story
they don't really succeed so just over
like Overlook that stuff I'm still
trying and uh just look at this as a as
a Sandbox to have fun in does have a rag
doll button yeah cuz if if you're
somebody who thought well GTA 4 doesn't
make any sense how is it that he's like
saying he wants so hard to get out of
this life but you're going around you
can go around murdering random people
like if that drove you crazy Watch Dogs
is going to make you go like literally
insane what I will find is that maybe
this is because Ubisoft don't have much
experience in the whole car driving
stuff but the the actual driving itself
feels a little bit weird the driving
does feel weird but I have to say I
actually really like the driving um the
reason I like the driving is because
it's a little floaty and a little bouncy
um some and because even though the cars
aren't cars we recognize these cars you
you know what it's going to feel like
before you get behind the wheel like you
you can look at it you can say oh that's
a you know that's a relatively heavy
sedan and it feels like a heavy sedan
and you get you get behind motorcycles
and and I don't know those I love
motorcycles in this game because they're
so fast and so weightless almost a heap
gamer in the chat was asking is there
much Variety in terms of the vehicles
there's a lot of variety uh let me see
if I can pull over and uh I can show you
go for it yeah we're at the end of the
show we we so we can just keep going so
okay let me get as long as you're happy
playing let's keep playing yeah I'll uh
I'll show you uh Park you can you can
order Cars on Demand and uh this gives
gives you an idea sort of of how many
different Vehicles you're you're able to
to order up you have to you can order a
fir truck yeah some of them are open to
you from the very beginning others you
you are only able to buy and you're only
able to buy them once you've ridden them
in the main world yeah so uh steal it
buy it then it's on demandable steal buy
it and then it's on demandable basically
yeah legendary myre ask can you shoot
the guy in the leg to make him fall down
this isn't that is a thing that will
happen yeah um but that's not it's not
really a no it's not really a meaningful
mechanic it's not something that I found
myself doing again because people die so
fast on normal difficulty so even if you
shoot them in the leg they they could
actually just perish from it yeah I yeah
totally I mean I shot that dude like
four times in some random place in the
body and uh so that's why buttocks and
upper thigh mostly but there are things
you can let's see if there's a random
person to just shoot sure so you can do
this sort of slow mechanic and then
sometimes that can be used in
interesting ways like especially if you
really do want to get that head shot in
oh this is dark but uh good thing
Kevin's aim is terrible yeah I know
right it wasn't like I was an actual
combat encounter so it's okay I I just
wanted to show you I didn't want to
actually kill the dude I appreciate your
restraint do R do r y I thought that was
around count oh God I should be on the
Sha method with the stupid
game he so that battery in the bottom
left there's like a limit of the amount
of like hacks you there's a limit of
hacks it replenishes um but then that
that grows over time so I want to show
you the skill tree for a moment but this
is this doesn't really tell you how big
the skill tree is because at this point
in the game you only have a limited
skill tree so everything's listed for
hacking driving crafting and combat yeah
so uh usually and and I would suggest
this for anybody the combat's easy
enough where I don't think you're going
to need to worry too much about combat
go with the hacking
or with the crafting if you like getting
well crafty in this game either way so
additional battery slot in this case I'm
going for Bridges because hacking into
brid my favorite kind of Escape let's TR
try and do that try and hack a bridge
all right let's see if uh if I can find
it you steal a
carge um and do you tend to get enough
skill points you can fill out the entire
tree by the end or do you do you really
I after 30 hours of playing I still
hadn't unlocked everything but I'd
unlocked most things
okay uh I thought the music in this game
was rubbish well the music is not good
in this game this song sounds not good
but like is it all licensed music that
they've got from as far as recognize any
songs I recognize artists I didn't
recognize songs I didn't like I
recognize you know a lot there's a lot
of hip-hop in the in the soundtrack I
and I recognize most of the artists but
I'd never heard any of the songs but for
me that's it's hard to say oh does that
mean that I don't listen to enough
hip-hop does that
me good songs but so here's here's a so
here's a bridge I'll hack into it and
then it starts to raise but this is this
is best used when you're you've got like
somebody on your
tail that is that is when um this is it
its best actually there it goes there
you go I missed it the first time I wish
somebody was on my tail so I could
really show you how fun that's my
favorite kind of escape this and the the
canal Escape what's the canal Escape the
canal Escape is basically there are no
cops in the water okay uhoh whoa do that
again try and hit the try and hit the
rdge no okay there's another Bridge here
I'll do this
one yeah oh that poor guy's freaking out
is like oh what oh he's up and over
double bonus jump video
games and I'm fine wow off the top rope
in a sports car let's see if uh
uh H Affinity asked did you play this
with the keyboard and mouse on PC at all
I haven't played any of the PC version
at all actually um the reason for that
is because you play sucks yeah it sure
does so uh yeah I I I wanted to start
playing some of the PC version today I
have not played the uh the past gen
versions either I'm I'm sad to say um I
went to I I played most of the game at a
review event um here in San Francisco on
the PS4 and then I played the Xbox One
version at home over theek again I got
one more question here GOI ride asks
what difficulty or sorry does difficulty
affect the cop
chases I did not notice a difference in
how in how cop chases were handled uh
oh again like as far as I could tell the
biggest change was how quickly people
went down when you shot okay okay um
it's interesting though like I wouldn't
I would say that the the cop chases in
general they can they can they can dog
you pretty hard um and that is not a
euphemism in any way there you go watch
dogs they can dog you pretty hard Kevin
vanord thank you very much in fact the
last question that came through is from
XD za1 1979 is that a real thing sure I
hope so cuz he says did you make that up
is
this he wants to salute Kevin as his new
favorite reviewer so your reviewer of
the game is on gay.com right now yes um
I gave it an eight cuz I think it's
great nice
great R what are you drinking is this
nine it's wine it's it's not wine it's
water this it's water we got branded mug
branded things oh yeah we we do but this
this isn't beer gam spot jar you're not
you're not honoring my hat he's
hydrating you're honoring me with your
hat and I appreciate it every day Kevin
much obliged I think we're giving away
some stuff here before we going do this
too sure fist pans all day long you want
to hang out and do that some more you
want to keep going with that okay we do
a three-way bum this is too much fist
bump sandwich I'm out that's right spit
roast all right finally we got some
winners here do you want to name at the
winners for our Watch Dogs giveaway sure
the winners for the Watch Dog giveaway
you got uh some Watch Dogs coming along
uh ninjatic yeah uh blue magician woohoo
or magian I can't tell lady Cactus 9116
all right girl Draco 7 yeah jeev
sxsw uhhuh get that out on my face not a
Twitter handle Alex M Schwartz there we
go so yeah you to you are all video
games getting Watch Dog games that Danny
has done interpretive dances with and
t-shirts guys I'm really sorry I fisted
you so much it's fine you know you're at
least a you're at least polite about it
Kevin and that's all we can ask and and
the monochroma winners should also be
getting the getting the heads up a bed
that we're sorry that Rob Handler got
your uh your swag topple sweat and stuff
H we'll be back next week uh Mario Kart
stream is starting directly after this
uh we apparently Nintendo have these
weird rules where you're allowed like
stream stuff for only 60 Minutes at a
time so we have used about 20 so far so
we're going to use the rest of the
allotment directly after this show so
stick around on Gamespot or twitch.tv/
Gamespot or on gamespot.com for more of
that uh adios E3 is on the way another
couple of weeks but we've still got more
lobbies in the meantime so stick around
here and we will see you next week
bye